You can't do it. I'm living in Malaysia,
and this is their Christmas. And isn't
it pretty?
It's truly beautiful.
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in Norway,
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a sadaqa jariya
for you because every person that comes
a step closer to Allah through your
donation, you will inshallah be reaping
the reward. Click the link and donate
what you can. As-salamu alaykum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh brothers and
sisters and dear friends. This video is
as you guys know every single year when
it comes to Merry Christmas. What is
Merry Christmas? Why do people say it?
Obviously, we do videos about Mussalah,
but that's kind of a bit of a lost cause
there. I don't mean entirely. I'm not
saying that. I'm just saying when it
comes to the Christmas thing. However,
we've got people, your general public,
or you know, influencers to some extent
who have trivialized this matter. And I
just want to give an analogy, and I just
want them to see if they would belittle
this matter as much as they do if we
just twisted a few dynamics here. Let's
watch this video of this sister,
who had a very problematic video before
talking about woman to be Korea
something like that. She took it down
anyways. But there's these two videos.
My dear sister again, look, you're my
aunt, you're an elder.
I don't want to be disrespectful towards
you. I want you to really understand
what you're promoting out there. And
anyone that's watching this, please
watch your tongues, guys. Okay, watch
watch your tongue. Do you not backbite?
Do not talk ill of her. We're just
trying to
maybe give some nasiha to the sister.
Okay, here's the first video. Let's see
about Christmas. She lives in Malaysia.
Let's see what she has to say about
Merry Christmas. Is it a right thing or
a wrong thing to say? I know that many
people in the UK have said to me, "Oh,
you can't say it cuz it means this or it
means that." But how are we supposed to
interpret? And how are we supposed to
invite? You can't do it. I'm living in
Malaysia, and this is their Christmas.
And isn't it pretty?
It's truly beautiful. The way that they
embrace everyone's cultures, everyone's
festivities.
Everyone is happy together.
And that to me is the true heart of good
Muslims.
Maya.
Maya Moana.
Hey. She's mini Moana.
What's the hell are you having in mind?
Don't bring me into a mall.
Malls are dangerous for any woman. I
don't care. I might try to be a certain
way, but
malls Oh, look at this Christmas tree
this Christmas tree.
Wait a minute. WAIT A MINUTE.
WOW.
LOVELY. OKAY, GUYS. SO, you saw that for
yourself. I mean, let's put things into
perspective. Number one, uh Christmas is
celebrated as Jesus' birthday. They're
celebrating Jesus being the son of God,
God himself, God incarnate, whatever you
want to call it. The Christmas tree
itself doesn't symbolize anything, but
it's a pagan ritual.
You all know that. We all know that.
Alhamdulilahi. Not only that, it's not
even a Christmas Christian thing for
that matter cuz you know when you read
the Bible, in the Bible in the Old
Testament, if I'm not mistaken, it says
very clearly, you'll have the reference
here, "Do you not go to forest, cut
trees, and adorn them?"
It's clearly said in Christianity that
you should not do it cuz it's some kind
of a pagan ritual. Now, to have a Muslim
woman like yourself to come here and
make it seem as if Merry Christmas is
nothing Oh, you know, what's wrong with
the decorations? We don't Islam uh the
judgment is not based uh based on how
things look. Oh, it's it looks so
lovely, etc. I mean, if something's
adorned and beautified, does that make
that right? For example, a strip club.
Yeah, a strip club. Now, a strip club
sounds not right to the ear, but guess
what? Let's change that to gentlemen's
club. Just play with Oh, it sounds
better to the ear. Does that make it
right? Okay, they're not called um uh
prostitution. It's called uh sex
workers. Or give it another title. Just
because you adorn it and make it look a
certain way, does not make it
permissible. Merry Christmas means what?
You're basically telling people, "Have a
lovely time, an amazing time associating
partners to Allah." Something that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says that the
mountains about to crumble and the earth
is about to split apart for the
statement that they make about Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala that he has a son.
Yes, the greatest of the greatest of
shirk
to us, yeah?
Now, I want to change the dynamics with
my dear sister. What if Merry Christmas
was known
if it was I'm just trying to give you
I'm trying to make this relate to you.
Yes?
What if it was made? And again, please
forgive me. I do not want to be
disrespectful. I need to make you
understand the severity of what you're
trying to promote, which is the
following. Imagine Merry Christmas was
that
it was a day that they insulted your
mother. They called your mother like I
said before like your dear mother. I'm
just trying to make you understand it
here. Imagine the day Merry Christmas
meant that this sister's mother me she
is called this this this this and this
full of insults like vulgar words
towards your mother.
And I went around and said, "I mean, you
know, I don't care. You know, back in
the day they you know, um it meant this
or it meant that. You know, I don't know
what it means, but I'm just going to go
around saying Merry Christmas." And
Merry Christmas meant that your mother
is this this this this and this. Would
you go around happily telling people,
"Guys, it's all right. Just go around
telling people Merry Christmas, you
know, it's it's the word actually means,
you know, what this means, this phrase
means that my mother is A B C D E. This
is what she They're insulting my mom. Go
ahead." Why? Because they've made a tree
out of it and whatever it is for that
matter. You would never do it. You would
never do it. You'll be so saddened.
You'll be so offended that people are
still celebrating a specific thing that
relates back to your mother, your family
members, whoever it is, your children,
whoever it is, and people are going
around saying this to each other. Now,
they might not have the intention of
that, but what is the phraseology known
for that? That is the point here. And
shirk, you should be far worse offended
cuz what I'm telling you now, you might
feel offended. I don't mean to offend
you. You should feel rather more
offended to that phrase
than if they were to insult my mom, my
generation, my kids, my wife, my whole
family.
I would rather they do that than come
and say statements of shirk. Because
Allah's rights goes above every human
being's rights. So, to me, if they were
to come and insult my If they said to
me, "Look, we're going to insult your
mom, your dad, your wife, your daughter,
your whatever you name it."
Or this, we're going to say this means
that Allah has a son. I said, "Please,
insult my family members. It's okay. I'm
happy with you insulting my family
members as long as you honor Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala." That is how our
attitude attitude should be. Not, "Oh,
what's wrong with Merry Christmas? Look
at the season. Look at it. It's so nice.
Look at the tree." Who cares? Who cares?
That's what the prophet said. You will
follow the
the disbelievers
handspan by handspan till that if they
were to go to a lizard's hole, you would
follow them. And they said, "Who are
they?" He said, "The Christians and the
Jews." Who else? You are following them
step by step. Okay? Our religion is
preserved.
Haram is clear. Halal is clear.
So, to us, please be very careful. You
will never promote this. And if I was to
do a video
asking people to insult your mom, you
would abhor it. You would go against it.
But when it comes to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala that feeds you, that gives you
your risk, you in one of your videos
bought a new house, etc. Where did all
that risk come from? From Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. He feeds you. He
looks after you. He's given you kids. He
makes your heart beat. And then you can
casually go and say, "What's wrong with
Merry Christmas?" There's a lot wrong
with Merry Christmas.
The Christians or whoever that matter,
they can celebrate it. We have nothing.
That's their religion. They do whatever
they like. But it is disappointing to
see a Muslim woman who observes the
hijab to come and tell us that Merry
Christmas there's nothing wrong with it.
There's great things wrong with it,
inshallah.
Uh and that's what I wanted to say,
inshallah. Till next time. As-salamu
alaykum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
We want to establish an amazing masjid
for the sake of
Click on the link and donate now for the
sake of Allah